as protesters have marched and gathered
in different parts of the city over the
past three months one of their cries has
been stand with Hong Kong it's a core to
their own people and to the
international community to support their
action against the increasing control of
China that runs Hong Kong under a one
country two systems policy they've
sought solidarity with Taiwan which
china views as a rogue province that
it'll eventually retake is fully
collapsed already we urge people in
Taiwan is time to safeguard Hong Kong
Lam winkie used to sell books in Hong
Kong that were critical of the Chinese
government and in 2015 was detained in
China for eight months this year he
decided to leave for Taiwan to avoid the
possibility of being sent back to the
mainland under Hong Kong's now withdrawn
extradition bill which was the catalyst
for the protests the power of the Hong
Kong government comes from Beijing and
it's become a dictatorship the people
have no voting rights so the government
can ignore their opinions and demands
there have been protests both Pro and
anti China in many cities around the
world the government in Beijing says the
movement is backed by foreign powers who
want to destabilize China the main
suspect is the United States which is
involved in its own dispute with China
the Donald Trump administration has
linked the Hong Kong crisis to the trade
negotiations so Beijing is also under
pressure not to be seen
in handling the Hong Kong issue Beijing
has warned that it may get tough soon
prompting concerns it could deploy
soldiers who are based in Hong Kong
since the start of the protests many
world leaders have expressed concern
about the situation in Hong Kong and
urged China to respect the rights of the
people here
those words have of course given
encouragement to the protesters but
those world leaders know that given
China's economic power there's only so
much pressure they can apply for now
China seems to be willing to be patient
in the hope that the momentum of the
protests will fade along with the
international attention on the streets
those fighting for the city's future are
determined to achieve the opposite lane
hey al Jazeera Hong Kong